si vous suivez ma chaîne vous savez que
j'aime vous parlez d'objets
technologiques en tout genre je vous
parle aussi bien de smartphones de
montres de tele2 plein plein plein de
choses et je vous parle également
d'objets technologiques pour la maison
et notamment dans ce cadre là je vous ai
déjà parlé plusieurs fois d'aspirateurs
connectés de la marque robot rock
pourquoi parce qu il vienne vraiment
apporter une solution pour votre maison
il vous évite de faire ménage vous
prenez donc du temps pour vous et
lorsque vous partez il fait beau à votre
place vous rentrez la maison est propre
et ça c'est génial
cette solution est bien mais elle n'est
pas parfaite non plus car l'aspirateur
ne peut pas passer exactement partout
hélas pas pouvoir tout faire il à
pouvoir couvrir avec 85 90 % de votre
intérieur et pour les quelques
pourcentages restant vous avez des zones
où la poussière reste où elles
s'accumulent et il faudrait une solution
alors aujourd'hui je vous présente un
produit qui n'est pas le produit le plus
technologique qu'on connaisse qui n'aura
pas l'effet waouh vous allez dire ce
truc là est génial mais par contre il
vient vraiment en complément des
produits de robots que je vous ai déjà
présenté c'est cette petite bête là
c'est l'aspirateur h6 de robot rock
c'est la f6 à date pour être extrêmement
précis c'est cette bête là
effectivement ici on n'a pas le produit
technologique avec le gros effet whaou
on va se dire want you grow tu nous
présente un produit extraordinaire qu'on
n'a jamais vus mais par contre ces
petites bêtes là elle vient vraiment
compléter ce que je sais déjà présenté
et c'est dans ce cadre là qu'aujourd'hui
et je viens vous le montrer
[Musique]
comment ça marche se trouve en vous avez
cette base vous appuyez sas pire vous
régler différents niveaux et après vous
avez beaucoup de choses à venir
connecter dessus et ça c'est cool donc
ça c'est la première chose ensuite vous
avez le deuxième partie c'est cette
espèce de gros tuyaux de majorettes
vous venez donc le connecter ici et
ensuite vous à 20 ans vous vous pouvez
venir collecter ce que vous voulez la
première chose qu'on pouvoir connecter
c'est cette espèce de grosse balayette
tac vous avez tout une bosse qui vient
tourner et qui va venir nettoyer super
facilement votre sol elle est pratique
pour les tapis mais aussi très pratique
pour tout ce qui va être literie et
notamment pour allait supprimer des
acariens mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisque vous avez plein d'accessoires
vous pouvez venir utiliser ça vous
l'enlever vous mettez ça à la base ça
aussi ça des toiles très très bien mais
ça ne s'arrête pas là puisque vous avez
une espèce de petit bourg 7 pour
nettoyer des sièges le sol de votre
voiture enlever les cailloux je vous
servira notamment pour votre clavier
d'ordinateur pour toutes les petites
donne un petit peu sensible et ça va
être aspiré dans tous les recoins où
vous n'aviez pas forcément accès très
facilement mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisque vous avez cette petite partie
pour avoir beaucoup d'inspiration sur
une toute petite zone
et ça c'est vraiment bien notamment pour
les radiateurs vous passer entre les
radiateurs des gros radiateurs en fonte
et vous enlever toute la poussière
messahel pas là puisque vous avez un
tuyau flexible que vous venez branché
qui pendouille vous allez pouvoir passer
où vous voulez faire ce que vous voulez
avec vos différents accessoires dont
dans tous les recoins vous ne pourriez
pas passer directement mais voyez vous
pouvez y arriver comme ça pourrait bien
venir aspirer votre aspirateur en lui
même c'est relativement pratique et
cette partie qui porte les accessoires
vient se fixer contre mur vous avez
votre prise secteur vous venez vous
brancher et lorsque vous prenez votre
aspirateur que vous l'avez fixé au mur
et bien vous n'avez plus qu'à venir
le clip ci dessus comme ça il se
recharge automatiquement vous mettez
tous dans un coin avec les différents
accessoires comme ça
tout aurait mon droit ici vous retrouver
sur le devant mon écran oled qui est
vraiment lumineux si vous allez inspirer
dans votre voiture et qu'il ya beaucoup
de lumière qui nous permettra quand même
de pouvoir élire très facilement
ça vous permettra de lire très
facilement ce qui est écrit donc ça
c'est bien une petite cachette pour rien
lancé l'arrêter et là vous venez le
bloquer ce qui fait que lorsque vous
appuyez là
voyez tabou le bloc choisissez la
position ici bloquez pas bloqué vous
bloquez vous appuyez s'inspire là vous
voyez le pourcentage de batteries
restant et vous avez trois niveaux le
niveau vous allez aspirer très doucement
le niveau intermédiaire et le niveau de
l'ue lorsque vous allez à fond c'est
très pratique parce que ça va tout
prendre tout aspiré point un petit peu
négatif est bien c'est que vous avez dix
minutes d'aspiration au maximum et au
bout de dix minutes
eh bien peut rien il se coupe et il faut
le recharger mais en mode eco vous
pouvez le garder 90 minutes vous avez
donc largement le temps de faire tous
les recoins de votre maison ici une
batterie développé par robot rock qui en
gros va être semblable aux batteries
qu'on peut retrouver dans nos smartphone
est un coup dur pour l'as donc ici un
produit qui est léger maniable qui fait
à peine un petit kilo 4 et qui est très
pratique pour la maison la poignée
plutôt bien et ergonomique il tient bien
en main pour effectivement un kilo 4 à
bout de bras au bout d'un moment ça vous
fait faire un peu de sport ça évite
d'acheter des haltères donc ça peut
rendre service et on si toutefois vous
en avez fini
c'est très facile vous levez ça vous
avez un petit nicolas c'est ce petit
bouton là vous vous mettez dessus vous
appuyez et ptak tout tombe
pratique on s'est toujours fermé et vous
êtes reparti et vous pouvez même tous
venir nettoyer parce que ça c'est quand
même bien mais regardez vous venez vous
tirez vous enlever ça vous avez accès à
votre fils que pourrait venir nettoyer
toute votre bac à poussière prévient
nettoyer mon bien évidemment on va pas
lavé le moteur parce que sinon on va
venir animer mais voyez c'est quand même
pratique facile entretenir pour ça
plutôt bien astucieux et puis vous
assurer que depuis que j'ai reçus j'ai
nettoyé notamment tous mes vieux
radiateurs en fonte et j'avais une
couche de poussière qui était assez dans
plein d'endroits où je n'allais pas
comme je ne fonctionne qu'avec
l'aspirateur robot rock le s6 et bien
arrivé un moment où ma maison est propre
il ya plein de petits recoins qui sont
pas faits d'où l'idée de ce complément
là c'est un produit qui est assez
silencieux si vous êtes en mode eco qui
fait 72 décibels
bon ça va par contre le modèle le mode
turbo
c'est pas la même mais il faut savoir ce
qu'on veut aussi le robot rock h si ça
date coûte 399 euros et pour lancement
vous avez une promo à 339 euros vous
invite tous les liens en bas dans la
description d'envoyer aujourd'hui on va
pas parler du produit le plus
technologique mais néanmoins il vient
vraiment en complément de produits dont
je vous ai déjà parlé qui sont vraiment
extrêmement intéressant pour la maison
si vous ne connaissez pas les candides
robot rock notamment le s5 max le s6 et
bien je vous invite à les visionner mes
vidéos que je croyais moi c'est vraiment
intéressant peut tout voir sur votre
smartphone vous savez exactement ce qui
s'est passé avec celui ci s'est
relativement différent mais par contre
ça viendra vraiment vous solutionner la
vie à vous de me dire devant vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire je
vous donne rendez vous dès demain pour
quotidien par les deux têtes allaient
des bisous et à demain
total
[Musique]